we cannot go to a middle school party  without knowing how to kiss your parents  have a CPR doll we can practice on that  may i kiss you what do you like about me  sweet smell good you're really pretty  CPR doll I can send in north wing  [Music]  really that swing is for sexing people  do sex on good boys rated R I'm having a  party tomorrow.you in can throw a locust  good guess and you're not the popular  kids in school don't get to that party  Oh God we're not robbing highway  fine I'll just live here good boys  graded our kid boys has read it on her  strong crude sexual content drug and  alcohol material and language throughout  all involving tweens tonight is a  response to kissing party did not go to  that party not knowing how to kiss we  can spy on my neighbor she's a middle  name she starts fires know someone who  has sex on land ends  good boy sprayed it on  you